messieurs bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors pour
commencer je vais me tourner vers
l'éditorialiste politique frédéric saint
clair notre maison commune est en
désordre on a entendu un cette alerte du
président français face à l'onu alors
comment est ce que vous comprenez cette
posture d'emmanuel macron finalement
c'est assez classique assez attendu une
critique des faibles réalisation d'un
projet multilatéral qu'il affectionne
particulièrement mais dont on a vu au
cours de différents moments de sa
politique que lui même prenait le
faisait le choix de 100 200 abstraire
les interventions par exemple en syrie
armés se sont faites en dehors du cadre
de l'onu en dehors du cadre multilatéral
donc en fin de compte ce
multilatéralisme est une belle idée
emmanuel macron comme l'ensemble des
présidents qui vont se déplacer à l'onu
vont vanté cette belle idée parce qu'on
sait pas faire autrement aujourd'hui
mais dans la pratique c'est une idée
extrêmement difficile à mettre en oeuvre
alors jean pierre guéno je rappelle vous
êtes historien ces mots notre maison
commune est temps de payer tant de
désordre c'est une formule finalement
tirés semble un peu à celle utilisée par
jacques chirac en 2002 on l'écouté puis
vous réagissez ensuite notre maison
brûle et nous regardons ailleurs
nature mais pile est surexploité ne
parvient plus à se reconstituer et nous
refusons de l'admettre
voilà notre maison brûle au sujet de
l'urgence climatique jean pierre guéno
est-ce que emmanuel macron marche dans
les pas de jacques chirac
en ce qui concerne sa relation avec
l'onu on est surtout dans une situation
paradoxale si on si on va rechercher
l'origine de tout ça au tout départ 15
ans après la création de l'onu
les choses semblaient mal partis avec la
france tout le monde a en tête le fameux
machin qui avait série et quand charles
de gaulle a désigné le temps à nantes en
quatre ans plus tard de gaulle avait
totalement changé d'avis parce qu'il
avait compris que l'eau et lui pouvaient
être quelque chose de très positif pour
lutter contre les les dominants contre
ceux qui semblaient dangereux la france
un privilège énorme il ya 193 membres
qui appartiennent à l'onu aujourd'hui il
n'y a que cinq membres permanents dont
la france à côté de ces géants que sont
les états unis l'ex union soviétique
la chine et la grande bretagne
c'est incroyable parce que la france
pourrait paraître lilliputienne par
comparaison avec les mastodontes dont on
a parlé surtout les etats-unis la chine
et la russie
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir
juste banques aujourd'hui pour emmanuel
macron comme pour chirac comme pour de
gaulle dans sa deuxième à partir de 64
l'onu est devenue un moyen
de retrouver un équilibre grâce à tous
les autres pays qui l'ont rejoint
d'éviter des situations frontale
d'éviter de faire que le la géostratégie
du monde soit le monopole des
mastodontes ou des blocs longtemps les
états unis l'union soviétique
aujourd'hui les états unis la chine avec
une posture aujourd'hui à cause de ou
grâce à donald trump tout à fait étrange
vis-à-vis des des principaux problèmes
critiques qui nous guette
on peut les rappeler rapidement
l'évolution des technologies numériques
évolution de la violence l'accroissement
des inégalités la crise climatique
l'évolution démographique et puis la
perle sur le gâteau aujourd'hui la crise
sanitaire
voilà donc c'est tout à fait intéressant
de voir cette tendance qui fait que
l'eau est lui qui nous a gênés quand
nous étions en pleine phase de
décolonisation avec algérie dont nous
refusions l'action lorsqu ils envoyaient
des casques bleus au congo dans la
sphère qui concernait les belges et bien
l'eau et lui est devenu un levier coutu
utilisons tous autres banques dans cette
lignée qui va de de gaulle deuxième
tendance à emmanuel macron en passant
par jacques chirat alors claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales nous a également rejoint
pour apporter son éclairage claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france
or votre rue gassion en votre réaction
pardon vous également à la prise de
parole des manuels macron ce discours
était aussi tourné en faveur du
multilatéralisme est ce que vous y avez
vu une pique envers les états unis
oui bien sûr c'est une pique envers les
états unis
je crois que pour poursuivre ce que vit
fikin être dit sur votre avec vos
intervenants
je pense qu'on peut dire que la france a
pu utiliser et peut encore utiliser
l'organisation des nations unies comme
un moyen de
relais de relayer son influence et elle
a souvent fait notamment avec des pays
qui votait dans le même sens qu'elle
alors souvent on a un petit peu critiqué
le fait qu'un certain nombre de pays
d'afrique de l'ouest avaient pour
habitude de voter avec la france mais
c'est vrai que la france a des relais d'
influence à travers l'organisation des
nations unies par ailleurs évidemment
comme ça vient d'être dit elle est l'un
des cinq membres permanents
c'était la construction de 1945 il n'y
aurait pas eu d'eau nu si on n'avait pas
donné le droit de veto à certaines
puissances et notamment au vainqueur de
la deuxième guerre mondiale
aujourd'hui ça pose un problème de
gouvernance générale puisque
effectivement d'autres pays sont devenus
puissants doivent exercer toutes leurs
responsabilités politiques au regard de
leur puissance économique et que ces
pays ne sont pas avant deux permanents
du conseil de sécurité
donc ça c'est le problème permanent et
d'ailleurs la plupart des membres
permanents se plaisent à répéter à des
pays de ce genre de ce que je viens de
citer comme par exemple le japon comme
par exemple l'inde que bien entendu et
il devrait être membre permanent du
conseil de sécurité
sachant pertinemment que cela ne se fera
pas en tout cas pas de sitôt parce qu'il
ya toujours un des membres permanents
qui a intérêt à s'y opposer
dans le cas des pays asiatiques la chine
n'a évidemment aucun nom aucune envie de
voir un autre pays asiatique devenir
membre permanent
alors le fait que les états unis et
critiqué le multilatéralisme en effet
est très préoccupant pour la france
parce que ce multilatéralisme est peut
être constituer un relais d'influencé
pour un pays qui est aujourd'hui une
puissance moyenne où on se souvient des
actions fortes de la france au sein de
l'onu on a entendu jacques chirac il y à
quelques minutes à à propos de l'urgence
qui m a dit qu on se souvient aussi de
dominique de villepin s'opposant à la
guerre en irak en 2003 aujourd'hui quel
est le poids de la france au sein de
de l'onu frédéric sinclair 1 sur 183
avec les réserves dû au fait qu'il siège
ce pays dans le conseil de sécurité ce
qui veut dire que les un droit de veto
et donc il peut s'opposer un certain
nombre de décisions
deux exemples premièrement le discours
de 2003 donc j'ai été conseiller de
dominique qui ne vivait pas ce n'est pas
remettre en question
premièrement sa pertinence en matière d'
analyse diplomatique et deuxièmement ça
sa stature de diplomates que de dire que
la france s'est refusée à participer et
c'est tout à son honneur
la guerre a eu lieu quand même deuxième
chose cette cette guerre
en réalité avait commencé en 2001 et en
2001 lorsque les attaques ont eu lieu
contre le world trade center
la résolution était votée dans la nuit
c'est à dire que l'onu s'est mobilisée
immédiatement pour dire on autorise on
valide le principe d'une réponse et
george bush junior a répondu qu' il se
moquait de ce que tout le monde pourrait
penser que les états unis étaient
attaqués et donc eux-mêmes allait
répondre et donc il ya eu un coup de
menton presque méprisant vis-à-vis du
multilatéralisme de l'onu et de
l'ensemble finalement des pays amis en
montrant cette volonté très républicaine
à aux états unis de dire on y va on sort
les musclés et on va frapper donc oui
cette cette instance
l'onu a une importance en droit parce
qu'elle elle est quelque part un horizon
vers lequel les pays doivent marcher et
non elle n'a pas l'importance quand
voudrait qu'elle est parce que le
bilatéralisme ou l'unilatéralisme
dominent encore les relations
internationales sur sur la planète
jean besoin
j'en tire guaino tout au long de ses 75
années est ce que la parole de la france
a évolué est ce qu elle a été plus ou
moins entendu en fonction des périodes
et l'a peut-être failli se pervertir
il faut rappeler quelque chose on ne
sait pas où est passé le manuscrit du
petit prince de saint-exupéry
on a retrouvé deux feuillets il ya
quelques années il y en a un qui est
porteur grandement porteur de sens dont
la version définitive du type passe
sa texture rappelle que deux milliards
d'habitants c'est le nombre de terriens
sur sa planète dans les années 40
pourrait tenir sur une île dont il se
contente de donner la taille
et puis dans le brouillon il il
détaillait il y avait tout le monde
parmi ces deux milliards d'habitants
les jeunes les vieux les jaunes les
rouges les blancs les noirs et puis
l'hymne s'est elle engagée lord
alors j'ai adapté la parabole de
saint-exupéry a aujourd'hui nous serons
dans quelques années 8 milliards
d'habitants 8 milliards d'habitants
debout collé serré pourrait tenir sur
une fois et demie l'île de corse que
voulait dire saint-exupéry et c'est
peut-être la voix humaniste que la
france peut porter en tout cas qu'elle a
commencé à porter avec de gaulle dans sa
deuxième manière le monde
la planète n'est pas démographiquement
surpeuplée pas géographiquement
surpeuplé nous sommes socialement et
connu une banque
économiquement surpeuplé pour deux
raisons d'abord le refus du partage
je rappelle qu'il ya dix personnes qui
abolissent 50 % des richesses de
l'humanité et puis surtout ou à côté de
tout ça le grand gaspillage
le grand gaspillage puisqu'un tiers de
ce que nous produisons de par le monde
face à la poubelle là il ya une voie
mais on parlait de l'unilatéralisme ou
de bilatéralisme certains pays remettent
en question tous les problèmes cruciaux
actuellement le problème climatique
refuse le partage ne refusent la théorie
du gaspillage est une certitude
il ya là une voie et si je dis qu'elle a
failli se pervertir c'est que le monde a
été pris
sous le joug de la folie d'un
ultralibéralisme que de gaulle redoutait
beaucoup de gaulle n'était pas anti
libérale il se méfiait des ultralibéraux
qui à ses yeux était aussi dangereux que
nesta ligne alors voilà est ce que la
france
geri de certaines tentations peut être
par par la pandémie par la coc div 19
est-ce qu'elle va atterrir et poussé le
monde à avoir une vision un peu moins
ultra libérale un peu plus sage un peu
plus humaniste en s'appuyant sur tous
les pays qu'ils évitent cette politique
de blocs cet impérialisme des états unis
de la chine ou de quelques autres que
nous évoquions tout honneur
alors il ya aussi quelques bémols la
france n'est pas toujours exemplaire
dans sa politique intérieure et
extérieure et l'onu lui a fait savoir je
vous propose de regarder quelques
exemples iront en réagi ensuite membre
fondateur de l'organisation
internationale la france semble depuis
plusieurs années dans le viseur de l'onu
une tendance qui s'accentue fin 2018
avec l'apparition du mouvement des gilet
jaune et son lot 2 heures hebdomadaires
entre manifestants et forces de l'ordre
en mars 2019
michelle bachelet la haut commissaire de
l'onu aux droits de l'homme exhortent
alors paris a diligenté une enquête sur
l'usagé excessif de la force lors des
rassemblements
une réclamation qui survient après
l'utilisation régulière du controversé
lbd lors des manifestations est à
l'origine de nombreuses blessures des
mises en garde envers la france qui se
sont répétées depuis plusieurs années en
2016 l'organisation internationale du
travail alertée l'état français sur le
contenu de la loi dit elle comme riz
pour l'institution onusienne la loi
travail provoquerait un affaiblissement
de la liberté syndicale et de la
négociation collective
autre critique qui fait tache au pays
des lumières celle du comité des droits
de l'homme de l'onu pour la loi
d'interdiction du voile intégral en 2018
une mesure qui selon l'instance viole la
liberté de religion
c'est ce même comité qui épinglait déjà
la france en 2014 pour son non respect
de la liberté de circulation aux gens du
voyage sur la politique extérieure de la
france
l'onu se montre également sévère
r sur le dossier libyen notamment
l'organisation internationale pointe du
doigt le soutien de la france au
maréchal haftar une décision qui la met
en porte à faux avec l'onu qui reconnaît
l'actuel gouvernement de tripoli
claude blanchemaison à ce que ce type de
remontrance peuvent avoir des
répercussions importantes
diplomatiquement
oui vous vous êtes donné un certain
nombre d'exemples que dans lesquels la
france n'a pas un comportement
exemplaire vis-à-vis les règles de l'onu
ou des différentes agences de l'onu
mais quel pays un comportement
exemplaire nous sommes dans le domaine
de la politique c'est à dire du
relativisme de ce qui est possible au
milieu d'un grand nombre de contraintes
est en effet peut-être que la france
respecte
au bout du compte et un ans l'autre plus
que notre les règle générale de l'onu
en tout cas on lui a su gré d'avoir
organisé une grande conférence sur
l'environnement
peut-être que là encore on peut lui
reprocher de ne pas avoir à ajouter aux
conclusions de cette conférence de paris
sur l'environnement des moyens de
contrainte pour obliger les états à
éliminer une par contre progressivement
les émissions de co2 sans fin qui
réchauffe le quai le climat qui
provoquent le réchauffement climatique
mais hélas aussi c'était l'art du
possible est l'art du possible c'est
qu'il n'était pas possible d'aller plus
loin dans les conclusions de cette
conférence
donc cette conférence sur le sur le
réchauffement climatique a montré la
voie à montrer la voie à suivre mais en
effet ne contient pas les éléments de
contrainte pour que les états membres
s'y plient et sur beaucoup de sujets
alors la situation des droits de l'homme
je pense que sur 193 pays il y en a pas
beaucoup qui pourrait ce que se placer
dans la catégorie des pays exemplaire y
compris dans les très grands pays
européens ou autres
donc là aussi il faut tenir compte des
contraintes politiques des contraintes
politiques du moment
la france a je crois à l'un dans l'autre
de très bons rapports avec l'ensemble
des organisations qui constituent le
système des nations unies
que ce soit le comité des droits de
l'homme que ce soit
l'oit et que ce soit l'unesco dont elle
dont elle abrite le siège et pour lequel
elle regrette qu'un certain nombre de
pays sera sorti refuse de financer
effectivement l'un dans l'autre je pense
que la france est plutôt est plutôt un
soutien fidèle des organisations qui
participent de la famille des nations
unies même sir sur certains points elle
peut être critiquée elle a tout à fait
accepté je crois fait critique alors en
tyka crise sanitaire vous en parliez à
l'instant claude blanchemaison défi
climatique
frédéric sinclair est ce que là comment
la france peut aider l'onu à se
réinventer aujourd'hui comment l'onu
doit se réinventer face à ces nouveaux
défis et puis tous ces conflits un peu
partout aujourd'hui dans la planète
je vais être assez je vais être assez
défaitiste 1 le donc le modèle de
l'onuci la société des nations la sdn
qui a été fondée par wilson en 19 à la
sortie de la première guerre mondiale
elle a fait long feu puisqu'elle s'est
effondré au moment où la montée des
fascismes et du nazisme a rendu clique
politique multilatérale impossible l'onu
aujourd'hui est confronté à peu près aux
mêmes problématiques c'est à dire une
intensification des problématiques
climatiques sanitaires mais également de
violence et puis de résurgence également
deux phénomènes identitaires religieux
terra qui pervertissent le bien fondé de
l'idéologie sur laquelle l'onu repose
c'est à dire que l'onu est une
organisation bienveillante dans sa façon
de penser et le problème c'est que la
politique des bons sentiments mac y
avait le disait qu'il faut que quelqu'un
qui fait profession d'être bon en toute
chose il faut qu'il s'effondre face à
ceux qui ne sont pas bons et bien
aujourd'hui
l'onu ne s'effondrera pas mais elle est
contrainte de s'agenouiller c'est à dire
que elle est contrainte de céder la
place aux accords bilatéraux aux
relations de puissance et à ce qu'on
appelle en géopolitique
le réalisme c'est à dire que healy a
parfois nécessité pour des raisons de
politique interne et pour des raisons de
géopolitique de mettre entre parenthèses
un certain nombre de principes qu'on
appelle un peu dans le commentaire
politique vulgairement bien pensants
pour la pâte pour faire preuve de
réalisme et de et d'exercer la
contrainte nécessaire sur les pays je
pense par exemple à l'influencé que
peuvent avoir certains nombres d'acteurs
dans la région du moyen-orient sur la le
terrorisme en europe sur l'évolution de
la résurgence islamique en europe et
notamment en france sur
l'instrumentalisation donc on voit bien
à quel point ces questions que sont
complexes
la question climatique exactement la
même on est fait partie comme l'a dit
monsieur blanchemaison des meilleurs
élèves en haïti en matière de respect
des normes climatiques
et pourtant on est quand même pointé du
doigt alors que des pays comme la chine
s'assoit dessus lamentablement vienne où
il nous reste quelques secondes le mot
de la fin sera pour vous et bien
rappeler l'histoire c'est un français
rené cassin qui en 1948
rédigé le projet de déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme c'est
ça qui doit servir de fil rouge et c'est
ça qui peut donner le le sens auquel il
faut s'agripper mais il ya une
préoccupation aujourd'hui il faut
espérer que les grands états n'utilise
pas la pandémie comme le disait
machiavel quand on gouverne les gens par
la peur quand on les tient par la peur
on tient le ram j'espère que la
stratégie actuelle de tout un tas d'état
ne consiste pas à utiliser la pandémie
et la peur pour éteindre les bougies
sociale car si c'était le cas s'ils ont
cherché à éteindre les bougies sociale
vous allez dire qu'on est dans le déni
et dans ce cas là les plus grandes
catastrophes peut se déclencher un grand
merci à tous les trois nous avoir
apporté votre éclairage ce soir au sujet
de l'onu merci à vous jean pierre guéno
je rappelle que vous êtes historien
frédéric saint clair merci vous êtes
éditorialiste politique et merci
avoue claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales